In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God and in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do
everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings want or desires and may you my beloved
divine will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy
will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive even a
breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints,
especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and
infuse in me true light so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. We're starting with April the 16th 1926 and we have some very wonderful
messages tonight. The first one is about abandonment and that true abandonment, the real abandonment,
the real giving of ourselves to God is what Jesus calls adoration. So Louisa said I was feeling so
very little and incapable of doing anything that I called my sweet mother to my help. Do you notice
the way Louisa tells us what to do when you're feeling totally inadequate and you just absolutely
wouldn't know what to think if somebody asked you. She says go and ask her blessed mother. She's
been there. She has done all the acts that need to be done. Enter in and join her. We're told right
at the very beginning and she said I called on my queen mother to help me so that together we might
love a door glorify my highest and only good. Okay and we're to do it for everyone and in the name
of all. Now I want you to notice that heaven and earth are praying together there. That's blessed
mother and Louisa, heaven and earth and that this spirituality of the divine will is a universal
spirituality. If anybody is left out you have not arrived at divine will because the divine will or
the essence of God cannot leave out any of his creation. And he doesn't look at us whether we're
good, bad, old, young, healthy or sick. We're his. We are his creation and that's the end of it.
And so we're to do everything in the name of all. So selfishness is completely obliterated.
Now you deal with those problems in the first four volumes. In the meantime I found myself
within the immensity of light at all abandoned in the arms of my celestial father. So God is light
the immensity of light is the divine will so I want to give you one John one five and I want to give
you one Timothy six sixteen God lives in unapproachable light. Now there's Louisa right in the center
and she's in the arms of the father. Okay so she cannot get any closer to God. Even more she said
I was so identified with him as though forming one single thing with him. Now there is the unity
in the divine will. That's it. That's the standard. She said that I no longer felt my own life.
I only felt God's life. Now there's Galatians 220. I no longer live Christ lives in me. Now
the rest of us talk about things like this but we're only on the way. We haven't come to this point
where you actually can't feel your own life. You only feel the life of God. But she said who can
explain what I experienced. Then afterwards Jesus came out from within my interior which of course
means the kingdom of God is in there. That is Luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians 3 16. And he told me
my daughter everything you experienced your full abandonment in the arms of the celestial father.
So now you see when Louisa said I was all abandoned and the arms of the celestial father
you might think in terms of just a simple hug. But Jesus is saying that she was abandoned
that her whole being was surrendered. That's a different matter altogether.
So your full abandonment in the arms of our celestial father no longer feeling your own life.
That is the image of living in the divine will. There you have it. So if you want an image of
living in the divine will there it is plain and simple. Okay in fact in order to live in the divine
will the creature must live more of God than of herself. Now in the very earliest volumes the
Lord takes you through what I call ordinary spirituality which is that you've got to let go of the
self and you've got to deny the self and you've got to God have a greater and greater space in
your life and so on. Now by volume 19 that should be past history and we should be ready for what
is being said to us here. Okay so our lives must be more of God than of ourselves even more than
nothing must give life to the all. I usually put that into a prayer every night and I say to the
Lord the I am not needs to find its fulfillment in the I am the only way that I can reach fullness
is in the I am. So the nothing in the all is the way Louisa puts it. When I say the I am not in the
I am I'm using the words of John the Baptist in John chapter one. So the nothing must give life
to the all to be able to do everything and to have her act at the top of the other acts. Now watch
this. Now we're going to have this a number of times. How can you have your act at the top of
other acts? Okay I'll read another bit for a while. You would have to have this kind of abandonment
to have your act at the top of the other acts of each creature. Such was the life of our blessed
mother. You're going to hear what the top means. She was the true image of living in the divine
will. She was totally abandoned to God. Her living in the divine will was so perfect that she did
nothing but receive from God continuously. That is the standard for us here in volume 19 that we
must receive from God continuously. She received all that she was to do in order to live in the
supreme volition. So notice we have the need to live in the supreme volition but the Lord himself
has to supply for us. We cannot possibly do it ourselves. So our blessed mother received the act
of supreme adoration. Watch this now. We're talking about the top. Okay. She received the act of supreme
adoration to be able to place herself at the top. That means at the pinnacle. The top of a mountain
is a pinnacle. The highest point of every adoration which all creatures were obliged to do for their
creator. In fact true adoration has its life within the three divine persons. Has its life
means has its source its origin in the three divine persons. Our perfect concord our reciprocal love
our one will form the most profound and the most perfect adoration within the most sacrosanctrancy.
Therefore if the creature adores me but her will is not in a quart of nine its vain. It's an adoration.
That means that I could sit in a church for two hours. I could say the nicest prayers and all the
rest of it. But if in some area of my life I am not willing to submit and to surrender my will
then Jesus is saying in this paragraph it's not actually adoration. You may be on the way but
you're not there you're not there. Now notice we're going to see the fallout from this as we go on now.
So you now know what the pinnacle is. Somebody is completely and totally surrendered to the divine
will. And therefore if they cloak all the acts of everybody else with their perfect adoration
then it means that every single person benefits in the eyes of God. Everybody everybody is lifted up
everybody is enabled to pray at a deeper level. Everybody is given grace to surrender at least a
little bit to God. So being at the pinnacle is very important. So my mother took everything from us
to be able to diffuse herself in everything and to place herself at the top, at the head, at the
pinnacle of every act of the creature. I think an old-fashioned way of saying that would be
mediatrix of all graces. So she was at the top of every love, of every step, of every word and of
every thought. She was at the top of every creation thing. She placed her prime act. That means the
greatest, the first class they standard. She placed her prime act upon all things and this gave her
the right of being the queen of all and of everything. And she surpassed in sanctity love and grace
all the saints who have been and will be as well as all the angels put together.
That that is incomprehensible to us because how do you even grasp the enormity of the holiness
of the saints in heaven and add all of that together and add all the holiness of the angels.
And he means all the saints from the first day of the church to the final day when the church
leaves the earth, the whole out of them. And that's because of her total and absolute
unconditional surrender at every instant of her life. So there was never ever a barrier
in her to anything that God wanted to do. So it's no wonder that the saints called her the delight
of God, our tainted nature's solitary, both. So the creator poured himself upon her, giving her so
much love that she possessed enough love to be able to love him for everybody. Now I want you to
notice the circle of love. We're going to have more of this in another message. I call it the circle
of love. God is love. He pours himself out on a creature and there must be the response of the
creature back to God. Otherwise the cycle of love is not complete. There's also a cycle of evil.
And that is that supposing I have an enemy beside me here, then this enemy hits out at me in some way,
verbally or mentally or physically or whatever. So a cycle of evil has begun. Now if I hit back
the cycle of evil is complete and evil now becomes established on the earth. And that's why Jesus
told us that when people offend you in any way, that you must respond with love because you break
the cycle of evil and you re-establish love on the earth. So every time the cycle of love is completed,
love becomes more and more and more and more established on the earth. And that's how the kingdom of God
will prevail over the Antichrist. All the acts of love that we do and they all will seem very
inconspicuous. Our little acts will seem nothing to us. And yet what they're doing is they're putting
in every single brick into the kingdom of God. That's terribly important. So let me just state
that again. The Creator poured himself into her. So the origin of love is God. And you'll always know
that you are truly loving because everybody will know there's something wonderful about this.
A human attempt to love without the divine really doesn't work. So the Creator poured himself upon
her giving her so much love that she possessed enough to be able to love him for all. Now there's a big
big secret for everyday life. And that is that if you meet someone that you naturally have a very
strong distaste for or you look at television and you see a group that you find yourself reacting
very negatively to, you can only respond with love if God gives you enough love for them.
So don't forget to ask Lord give me the love that you want me to give to that person or to those
people because their source of love is heaven. So God communicated to our blessed mother the highest
concord and the one will of the three divine persons in such a way that she was able to adore
for all in a divine manner. Now there's the issue that we learn how to actually adore God
in a divine manner. You can only do that in the divine will. It's not possible. It has to come from
himself. And therefore because you love him and adore him in a divine manner, you can make up for
all that lacking in all the others. And when I say all the others, I mean all creatures from Adam
to Zachary the whole lot. Had it not been so Jesus said it would not be a truth but just a
manner of speaking that our celestial mother surpassed everybody in sanctity and love.
In other words, it'd only be words empty words. But whenever we speak as the most holy trinity,
it is facts, not words. This is very important. When God says something, he creates that something.
Let there be light and he creates light. Let us make man in our own image and he creates
man in his own image. Whatever he says will happen. And so when God speaks, he puts that word into you.
So don't forget to say to him, put your word of love in me. Put your word of life in me.
Put the life of your divine will into me and allow me to live at this very profound level.
Therefore, the most blessed trinity found everything in our blessed mother.
And having found everything and every one, that means you and me as well.
We gave her everything, constituting her queen and mother of her very creator. It's absolutely
astonishing what we're reading there. But if you look at the fact that the blessed trinity gave you
and me to her that she is to mother us, then we simply go to her and ask her to bring us to the
place that we're supposed to be. So in the next paragraph, then Louisa is told that at our own
level, she is to follow suit. Because our blessed mother was the one to bring the redeemer to the
earth and therefore bring redemption to the earth. And Louisa is the one to bring the divine will to
the earth, so the head of an era of a mission. So now daughter of my supreme will, one who wants
everything must enclose everything and place herself at the top of the acts of all. Therefore,
Louisa has to put herself at the pinnacle of all the acts done in the divine will. She has to.
Otherwise, she's not the first. She's not the one who opens the door. So the soul must be at the top
of every love, every adoration, every glory of each creature. Now we have to remember that when
we're praying, my will is everything. And this is why the mission of the sovereign queen and yours
can be called one because it's everything to do with divine will. And you must follow step by step
the way that she conducted herself with God to be able to receive the divine attitude
in order to have within yourself a love which says love for all. Now I think that is the great,
great, great transformation has to happen in us to turn us from worldly interests and self-interest
to divine interests. That's a huge change. If you think it's easy, it hasn't happened to you.
It happens to us with great pain, great difficulty. Let me just go over some of that again.
You have to be able to follow step by step what Blessed Mother did to be able to receive
the divine attitude in order to have within yourself a love which says love to all.
All political enemies, social enemies, spiritual enemies, whatever they are. Okay.
I remember a moment of real freedom. Not so long ago either. Having been attacked enormously
spiritually by the enemy. And I just said to the Lord one day, Satan will do what Satan does
and you'll do what you do and make sure I'm on your side. Just make sure that my vote is your
side all the time. And it doesn't matter about him. We're going to pay no attention whatsoever to him.
It was great liberation. So we have to be able to receive a divine attitude in order to have within
yourself a love which says love for all. An adoration which adores for all. Now I find this very
important. I like to pray like this at night for all who are dying. That we pray for them. We love
for them. We adore for them. We surrender for them. We repent for them. We saturate them in the precious
blood of the lamb. Everything because they're in their most important journey. And that's the journey
from our side to God's side. And we literally got to take them by the hand and love them into life.
You must be our echo and the echo of our celestial mother. So the blessed Trinity loves for all. Blessed
mother loved for all. Louisa has to love for all. We have to follow Louisa and echo her, echo
blessed mother and echo the blessed Trinity as well. So you must be our echo and the echo of our
celestial mother because she alone lived perfectly and fully in the supreme volition. Therefore
she can be your guide and act as your teacher. I think that's a pretty good statement to make.
Watch that one. If you are looking at your own notebook, make sure you mark it. She will be your
guide and she will be your teacher. If you knew with how much love I am around you and how much
jealousy I watch over you, the Lord is jealous that you know the few people he has who are willing to
live in the divine will. He's very jealous that the enemy doesn't get in and pull us back in anyway.
So he watches over us. But I think that's a lovely thought that the Lord is watching over you,
like he'd watch over a baby in a cradle. I watch over you so that your living in my will may not
be interrupted. It's not interesting. You must know I am doing more with you than I did with my
very celestial mother. Of course, yes, because our blessed mother didn't have original sin.
Because she did not have your needs nor any tendencies to passions which might even slightly
prevent the course of my will in her. You'll know if the passions can still be stirred negatively.
If you watch something on television and find yourself getting angry about it,
then you take note and say, Oh, I'm getting away from this. With the greatest ease, the creator
would pour into her and she into him. There was just no block. It was like, excuse my awful image,
two buckets of water flowing into each other. It was the greatest of ease. My will was always
triumphant in her. There's another prayer we need to pray to ask the Lord to triumph in us. Because
if the divine will triumphs in us, then he doesn't ask anything else. That's all he's looking for.
And he's been looking for that since the time of Adam. Therefore, our blessed mother had no need
of either spurs or admonitions. And you'll see that in all the volumes leading up to volume 19,
Jesus has had to coact Louisa and show himself to her and carry her and console her and all
the rest of it. Because the level of life he was asking her to live was absolutely way beyond
anything that was known before then. So with you, that's Louisa. On the other hand,
I must use more attention. When I see some little passion, some little tendency wants to rise in
you. And also when your human will would want to have some act of its own within you, I must
admonish you. Now, what I find fascinating about that is, we're in volume 19. Louisa has been
through hell and high water. She has experienced so much suffering. She has experienced so much
grace. And still the Lord will say that your human will can still want to express itself.
So don't be surprised that you and I find the human will expressing itself much more frequently.
Even though you don't want it, we're in the same position as Saint Paul in Romans chapter 7.
I do the things I don't want to do and I don't do the things I want to do. So I find that
fascinating coming in here at this late stage. The power of my will must remain in the act of
knocking down whatever arises within you, which does not belong to it. Therefore,
if you're trying to live in the divine will and you are not being purified continuously,
there's something wrong. There really is something wrong because we're brushing up against our own
fragile selves and brushing up against the fragility of other people and the things
that happen to us in the world. We are being challenged moment by moment. Okay? And even if
nobody else is getting at you, your own personality and character can be enough to keep anyone going.
So the divine will has to keep knocking down the blocks to itself that are inside of us.
And therefore when you find something going against you in your everyday life, not my will,
but die and be done, not my will, not my will, not my will. We have to say that until we hear it,
he hears it all the time. But we need to hear it. And so my grace and my love must flow into that
rot. Now the rot is the human will expressing itself and therefore blocking the wonderful
transformation that God is trying to do in us. The rot that the human will keeps forming or
with anticipated grace is prevent the rot from forming in the soil. Now sometimes he does that
and you only realize afterwards that he actually lifted you up and took you to a different place
to where you would have fallen. This because I love the soul so much and that is the soul
who lives in my will and in whom the Supreme Fiat has its field of divine action. In other words,
he loves with such divine love, a soul that allows him to work in us on earth.
And he has said this many times over the volumes that in heaven everything is conquered,
everything is his on earth, he's working hard, he's trying to conquer more souls.
And she costs me so much that I love her and she costs me more than all creation and redemption
itself. I find that unbelievable. So what he's saying is you are a very precious but costly jewel
and he loves you. It's very important to just recognize what he's saying. In fact, the creation
was the beginning, the beginning of our work towards the creatures, the redemption was the means and
the fiat is the end. So there's the three fields working together. And when works are accomplished,
they are loved more and they acquire their complete value. Until the work is accomplished,
there's always something to do to work on to suffer nor can one calculate its right value.
But when it is accomplished, all that is left is to possess and to enjoy the work done.
And its complete value comes to complete the glory of the one who has formed it. So just
think the image of a sculptor trying to make a very beautiful statue and he's got to keep on
working on it until he gets the final thing that he actually wants. I'm using that image
because of Genesis chapter two, because you're told that God fashioned man and then he was so
delighted with what he did that he put a soul into him. Therefore, creation and redemption
must be enclosed in the supreme fiat. That's why we do rounds of creation and redemption.
Do you see then how much you cost me and how drawn I am to loving you?
Now watch this, the fiat operating and triumphant in the creature is the greatest thing for God.
Now if you have your own book, will you color that in green, white and gold?
I'll read it again for you. The fiat operating and triumphant in the creature that's in us
is the greatest thing for God. We can give God immense joy, immense joy. I think that's wonderful.
Because the glory which was established by us to be received through creation
is given back to us and our purpose, our rights, acquire their full power. This is the reason for
my intention, why I'm all for you and for my manifestations to you and for my love for all creation and
redemption. Everything is centralized in you because in you I want to see the triumph of my will.
He's speaking to Louisa there and in a lesser sense he's talking to us because we're not the head,
she was the head. So let's come to April the 18th 1926 and he's likens the divine will to the wind.
It's very very interesting if you look in the scriptures. Sometimes you don't know from the
prophets whether they're talking about actual wind or the Holy Spirit because the Holy Spirit
is called Ruach or UACH Adonai. Ruach is wind, so it's the wind of God. Adonai is the Lord.
Okay, so Louisa said, "I felt all shrunken within myself and I tried to fuse myself in the Holy
Divine will to run along with it so as to keep it company in its works and to requices at least
with my little, I love you." So there she's doing her rounds and trying to pull what I call your
signature on everything that God has done. Now while I was doing this my sweet Jesus coming out from
within my interior told me, "My daughter, courage, do not pay attention to your littleness." And that's
very very very very interesting. What you must care about is to keep your littleness in my will.
Human beings are absolutely extraordinary. We can get used to anything and we can get
caught on anything. We can get attached to anything. We can even get attached to our littleness.
It's crazy. And so in the early volumes of studying Louisa it's going to sound like a
contradiction but the big thing is to get small and the great issue is to get small enough to
really be down there so that God can work in us. But you can become attached to that and my
littleness is my possession. Now if that's the case we're wrong. So he's saying that the thing
to care about is that the littleness is in the Divine will because if the littleness is in the
Divine will everything that God wants to do will be done. He doesn't care whether we're little or
big. We're all infinitesimally small by comparison with God. So because by being in the Divine will
you will be dissolved in it and my will, like the wind, will bring the freshness it possesses into
your act as refreshment for all creatures. Now it's the wind of the Divine will coming into this
littleness is going to do all this wonderful work on the earth. It will bring a warm wind to inflame
them with my love. It will bring a cold wind to extinguish the fire of their passions. And finally
it'll bring a humid wind to produce the vegetation of the seed of my will. Now notice the language
there, the vegetation of the seed of my will. If you go back a few weeks ago, Jesus was talking
about how our blessed mother became the mother of the Savior and through every one of her acts in
the Divine will the seed of the Divine will, the seed began to fecundate is the word the translator
uses and until she was able to actually conceive the Son of God himself. So he's saying that we have
to allow the seed of the Divine will to develop in us as well. Now in Louisa it was to bring about
the whole era of the Divine will and you know it has got to be that all of us together because
we're very much smaller than Louisa that we're laying down the red carpet for Jesus' return.
All our little acts, all our little nothingness, it's wonderful. So
have you ever experienced the effects of the wind, how it can turn the air almost instantly
from warm into cold, from humid into most fresh and refrigerating air. Now people in hot countries
that image is very very very good for them but in cold places like us not so wonderful we would
say cold wind you know even though that they say the temperature is 12 it's not 12 because we
have the wind chill but in hot countries what Jesus is saying is incredible I've lived in Africa
and a cool wind is something completely divine and it just clears the air from the suffocating
stench that goes with everything being hot. So he says my will is more than the wind and it makes
your acts in it by agitating them move the winds it contains to produce admirable effects. So it is
God working within us we are the ones surrendering we are the ones abandoning all the time then
all these winds united together invest the divine throne and bring to their creator the glory of
his holy will operating in the creature. Oh if everyone knew what it means to operate in the
supreme fiat and the tragedies it contains they would compete with each other in order to live in it.
So see he says our will is so great that we ourselves make it the depository of our works so
the blessed Trinity puts all their works into the divine will. In our will we deposited the creation
that it might remain ever beautiful fresh whole new just as was issued from our hands. In our will
we deposited the redemption that it might be always in the act of redeeming and my birth my life my
passion and death might be always in the act of being born living suffering and dying for the
creature. In other words once it is done on a divine level it's done forever. In fact our will
alone has the power to maintain the work done always in act and to reproduce the good as many
times one wants. Now the people of Israel they chosen people had an inkling of this they kind of
understood in a way that when they celebrated Passover every year that the graces that were
given to Moses and the people in the first Passover was actually given to them and they were right
even though the whole thing was done on a lower level than we're at here but the same principle
applies and they understood that so at every Mass it's a Calvary and all the graces of Jesus dying
are there. So our works would not be safe Jesus said if they were not deposited in our will well
where else would you deposit them because it wouldn't be safe anywhere much more so should it be with
the works of the creatures. To how many dangers are they not subject when they're not deposited in
our will well that's true if you deposit them in your own self forget about it. How many changes
do they not undergo therefore all our contentment is when we say that the creature makes the deposit
of her acte in the supreme volition. These acte though small also the little trifles of the creature
now this is something terribly important many people think that the acts we do have all got to be
prayers or actions if I could put it that way and for the Lord it isn't that it's your seeing
your hearing your tasting your touching your walking your smelling you're lying down to sleep
you're getting up all the acts that make up your life go into the divine will and when they do
the divine will is safe inside of you. These calling them the trifles of the creature because you
have to do these things anyway to stay alive they compete with our acts and we delight in seeing
her industriousness that in order to place her trifles in safety she deposits them in our will
everything. I remember somewhere that louisa said even the blinking of her eyes for someone
own reason that really touched me. Now if our will was the depository of creation and of redemption
it must also keep the deposit of the fear on earth as it is in heaven. Here is the reason for
my pushing so that you may do nothing without depositing it in the divine will that's why he keeps
moving louisa along the woman who's living at a level that I think was way beyond heroic because
she never got a second off there was no relactation at any point and there's something enough that
sort of reacts to that we sort of need time to breathe. If you do not form this deposit of
all of yourself of your little acts and even of your trifles not having its full triumph in you
my fiat will not be able to carry out its fiat on earth as in heaven. So I think you're looking
at there a very complete and total response to Deuteronomy 6 4 to 10 that you should love the
larger God with all that is a hundred percent all your soul all your mind all your will all your heart
okay so coming into April the 25th 1926 we're coming into the circle of love okay and we're going
to be talking about that. I'm going through most bitter days louisa said because of the privations
of my sweet Jesus. I feel I am breathing a poisonous air which is enough to give me not one death but
a thousand deaths. But as I'm about to succumb under the mortal blow I feel a vital and balsamic
air of the supreme volition which serves me as counter poison so as not to let me die. Now we've
heard this phenomenon many times before now if the Lord is getting her to really do reparation for
something on the earth she says she's brought right to the point of death and then suddenly the divine
will brings her back to life. So this vital and balsamic air of the supreme volition serves louisa
as a counter poison so as not to let her die and she said it keeps me alive that I may suffer
continuous deaths under the incalculable weight of the privation of my highest and only good. Now if
you will remember it is in volume 17 or 18 that louisa was told that the weight of the world was
on her back then this incalculable weight is that she's carrying all souls and she's making
reparation for them all. Oh privation of my Jesus how painful you are she said you are the true
martyrdom of my poor soul. So louisa would be undergoing what the Irish call quite martyrdom
that red martyrdom is when you spill your blood. Oh supreme will how strong and powerful you are
by giving me life you prevent my flight into the celestial fatherland now she's been complaining
like that since very early in these volumes to find the one that I so much long for and desire.
Now the difference between someone very close to God and someone who has a religion and is just
doing the ordinary things of religion is that someone very close to God wants to go to him
wants to be in heaven. I mean saint Elizabeth you couldn't wait she said no I'm a spring flower
I'm going I'm going early louisa lamented for years and years and years that she was kept
being brought back all the time she wanted to go to God and you will find among many Christians
they're not interested at all in going to God they want to get on with a living on the earth and
being as comfortable as they can so from people's reaction to passing into the next world you actually
see where they're at and so she says please I have pity on my heart exile pity on me who live without
the one who alone can give me life okay so when I was feeling crushed under the weight of this
privation my beloved Jesus moved in my interior and fixed his gaze on me must be a wonderful thing
to help the case of Jesus fixed on you as his compassionate gaze I felt restored from death to
life he only has to look he doesn't have to say anything it's absolutely amazing and since I was
doing my usual acts in the supreme volition now notice she will persevere and do her acts regardless
of how she's feeling herself there you have somebody in real holiness they will serve the Lord
regardless of how they're feeling themselves Jesus said to her my daughter while you were
impressing your I love you in my will upon all creation things all creation felt the love of its
creator being doubled and since creation things do not have reason that love flowed with impetus
towards the one who created them so there you've got the love going back to God from earth through
Louisa and the celestial father in seeing the love that he issued in creation being doubled by the
little newborn of his will so as not to be surpassed in love he redoubles his love and makes it flow
overall created things in other words when we do these acts of putting our I love you on everything
and taking them back to the throne of the father he redoubles the love for the whole of creation so
we're doing a massive thing for everybody around us absolutely massive and the health of the earth
and the restoration of the earth and everything depends on it he redoubles his love and makes it
flow overall created things to follow the same course which is it'll offer it followed so she
goes around with everything with her I love you and then he goes around redoubling his love which
I think is fantastic and then she goes at it again and he doubles it again and she goes at it again
and he doubles it again so if you're good at mathematics you'll see this spreading out exponentially
then he centralizes all his love in the one who sent him his love doubled that's the important
bit when he sees the love coming out of this little creature and going up to him and she will come
back and do the same thing again the following day and the following day and the following day
and the following day then he centralizes all this love in her and the amount of love she has for
creation and for everything that God has done increases and increases and increases exponentially
and with paternal tenderness he awaits the new surprise that his little reborn will double his
love again okay therefore in the next paragraph we're going to hear that this operation of sending
this love to God on behalf of all creation actually makes created things more friendly towards us
and you should really take note of this and test it out a little bit okay oh if you knew the currents
and the waves of love which come and go between earth and heaven and from heaven to earth how all
the things of creation through their mute language that's Sam 19 verses 1 to 6 and without intellect
they feel this doubled love of the one who created them and of the one for whom they were created now
that's Romans 8 19 since Louisa is the one bringing the restoration of the earth they feel the love
for her as well that means creation becomes more friendly to us now if you go back to the book of
Genesis you will find that all of creation was friendly to man there was no such thing as a wild
animal until the fall and then since the plants and the animals were still doing God's will they
moved away they became wild if you like and so here you have the restoration of the relationship
between someone living in the divine will and the creatures of God okay so let me read a bit of that
again if you only realized how for all the things of creation through their mute language and without
intellect they feel this doubled love of the one who created them and they feel it of the one
for whom they were created because they were created to serve man and they all assume an
attitude of a smile a feast and of letting flow benevolent at their effects towards creatures
just to give you a small example of that that means the birds sing more sweetly
that the flowers become more beautiful that the animals become more friendly towards us
try it out and see does it happen for you and ask the Lord to increase the level of your living
in the divine will so in the rest of this message then the Lord is saying that his fiat is triumphant
and heaven but is still on a conquering tour on earth the living in my will moves everything Jesus
said as the first thing it moves everything that is us living in the divine will secondly it invests
everything and thirdly it fulfills the work of creation and redemption what a reason to be alive
it's absolutely amazing the fiat on earth as it is in heaven has a tragedy a note more harmonious
a characteristic more beautiful which it does not enjoy and possess even in heaven because it's
conquering the earth in fact in heaven the divine will possesses the tragedy of the fiat of absolute
triumph which no one can resist and all the enjoyment in the celestial regions come from the divine
fear because we've been told many times that the divine fear is the source of all happiness
but here in the exile in the depths of the soul the divine will contains the
tragedy of a conquering fiat conquering us and through us conquering the world and of new conquests
that's conquering the world so while in heaven there aren't new conquests because everything belongs
to the divine will in the pilgrim soul my fiat is not absolute but wants the soul with divine will
in its own work that's why the lord wants us more and more and more surrendered to him and so the
divine will delights in manifesting itself in commanding and even in praying her to operate
with it and when the soul surrenders and lets herself be invested with the supreme fiat
such harmonious notes are formed produced on both sides that's ours and his
that the creator himself feels cheered by his own divine notes now this is the second time tonight
we have come across the the simple thing that we can actually give joy to god i think it's fantastic
so god himself or the creator himself feels cheered by his own divine notes coming from the
creature these notes do not exist in heaven because heaven is not a dwelling place of works
it's a place of enjoyment therefore my fiat on earth has the beautiful characteristic of impressing
its own operating within the soul and making her the repeater of its works so in heaven
my fiat is triumphant and no one in the celestial regions can say here i've done a
work to prove my love my sacrifice to supreme fiat that is over for them their journey is finished
okay but on the earth the fiat is conquering and if one likes the throne that means
if the divine will likes to reign that's what it means much more does one like new conquests
indeed what would my fiat not do in order to conquer one soul look at that
because through medieval torta the lord said very clearly that god loves all souls with exactly
the same love with which he loves one and he loves one with exactly the same love with which he loves
all the others there's no distinguishing between the love that he has for you and he has for me
so indeed what would my fiat not do to conquer one soul at to make her operate in its volition
how much has it not done and has it not done for you okay so afterwards anyway
louisa says my jesus made himself seen crucified and he was suffering very much
i did not know what to do to relieve him i felt annihilated by the privations as suffered
and jesus on nailing himself from the cross through himself into my arms telling me
helped me to placate divine justice now i find this totally amazing but we've got this from volume
one where louisa had her vision at the balcony of seeing jesus going down a street in korado
and he looking up to her and saying a soul helped me okay have me to placate divine justice for it
wants to strike the creatures a strong earthquake could be felt such as to cause the destruction of
towns i was left frightened jesus disappeared and i found myself inside of myself so it is extremely
important for us to unite our sufferings with those of jesus and in the divine will to make
reparation for all and at the moment of history that we are actually living in this is vital absolutely
vital i'm not going to start a new one because it's five to eight and that would take me on quite a
bit because the next one is long so i think it's very important to emphasize that with all that
has gone wrong in the church and all that has gone wrong in the world that we have the privilege
of making reparation in the divine will for the whole thing and therefore we are guaranteeing
that as many souls as possible today will be saved one of the things i like to actually name
is i say to the lord i'm asking you that as many souls as possible among the seven billion that are
on the earth today i want as many of them to come through i don't want scores and scores and scores
of people to be lost so whatever the the trouble you have and whatever the pain you have the lord
has to allow you to have trouble and he has to allow you to have pain otherwise you have nothing
to give him and we put this tiny little nothing in with his sufferings and with his divine will
and he works the miracles so you want to stop there for tonight